dieser mann hat ein todsicheres
geschäftsmodell
er verdient an den verlusten anderer am
online glücksspiel
wir spüren in echtem geld machen über
eine million euro umsatz im jahr
und davon sind so ein gutachter betrag
im monat beginnen
nennen wir ihn kam möchte anonym bleiben
karl stream täglich auf youtube und
switch verzockt so wie er machen es
dutzende andere streamer und bekannte
influenza ein gutes geschäft mit dem
online casinos weltweit rund 40
milliarden dollar umsetzen
das geld kommt von menschen auf der
suche nach dem großen gewinn die sascha
ich habe von meinem glücksspiel circa
180.000 euro verlor ein vermögen
dabei ist grenzenloses online
glücksspiel in deutschland bislang noch
verboten
saschas verluste und karls gewinne
eigentlich dürfte es sie nicht geben
gibt es aber hier auf youtube auftritt
warum das wollen wir in diesem film
herausfinden
die antwort auf diese frage führt von
sascha und karl über klasse und seine
promi freunde bis nach malta
[Musik]
das ist jens knossalla kate moss er ist
mit über einer million followern der
erfolgreichste casino streamer
deutschlands täglich schauen ihm
tausende dabei zu wie er live in online
casinos um geld spielt da sollten besser
aufpassen was er da publikumswirksam
inszeniert nicht dass da noch ein
staatsanwalt zuschauer im
strafgesetzbuch verbietet auch unter
strafe die teilnahme an illegalen
glücksspielen knapp streamt es trotzdem
und kommt damit gut an
deutsche promis zeigen sich gerne mit
ihm wie würdest du jetzt freunden zum
beispiel erklären jetzt nicht ins nichts
zu tun haben wie würdest du den erklären
was der so beruflich macht ja es ist ein
streamer die klassische streamer wie
knapp sie sind die influenza innen der
online casinos werbe ikonen des zockens
später wird ein streamer uns erklären
wie das geschäftsmodell funktioniert das
ihn reich macht warum überhaupt schauen
so viele einem streamer dabei zu wie er
sein geld in online casinos auf den kopf
haut sascha hat genau das über jahre
gemacht seine glücksspiel karriere
beginnt mit einem zwei-euro-stück an
einem spielautomaten als auch online zu
spielen beginnt geht es schnell bergab
ich habe online glücksspiel circa
180.000 euro
es wird relativ schnell im online casino
keinen sitz im online casino kann zu
setzen was du willst online glücksspiel
ist in deutschland eigentlich verboten
sascha dürfte sein geld gar nicht
verloren haben aber die lage ist
komplizierter
online glücksspiel ist in deutschland
grundsätzlich verboten dass sich der
geltenden staatsvertrag so eindeutig vor
eine ausnahme gibt es allerdings die
betriebsschließung holstein ein
irrwitziges regelwerk in 15 von 16
bundesländern sind online casinos
bislang nicht zugelassen
in schleswig holstein können sie
lizenzen erwerben aber nur für nutzer
innen in schleswig-holstein sascha aber
lebt in rheinland-pfalz aber klar
casinos im internet halten sich nicht an
deutsche ländergrenzen das verbot läuft
ins leere
deswegen haben sich die länder in einem
gesetz nun auf neue regeln geeinigt
online casinos sollen 20 21 legalisiert
werden in allen bundesländern eine gute
idee
nein sagt zumindest ilona
füchtenschnieder
sie arbeite täglich mit spielsüchtigen
ist suchtbeauftragte in
nordrhein-westfalen inhaltlich
kritisieren wir an dem an dem gesetz den
ganzen bericht den das gesetz quasi hat
der spielerschutz und der schutz der
bevölkerung steht nicht an erster stelle
also es wird soll vergessen werden dass
glücksspiel ein demo rhetorisches gutes
ein gut dass schäden verursacht für die
gesellschaft für jede gesellschaft in
der es ist durch das glücksspiel habe
ich meine freunde verloren ich habe
meine familie verloren ich hätte damals
fast meine wohnung verloren
ich habe geld verloren ohne ende ich
habe mein selbstbewusstsein von ich hab
eigentlich alles verloren was man so als
mensch hat bis das online glücksspiel 20
21 legal ist gilt eine übergangsregel
online glücksspiel bleibt illegal wird
aber nicht mehr strafrechtlich verfolgt
ein zweifelhaftes vorgehen sagt der
jurist
ob das tatsächlich auch in
gerichtsverfahren dann so bestand haben
wird da muss man ein großes fragezeichen
dahinter machen dass das online
glücksspiel illegal ist wusste sascha
nicht dass seine gewinnchancen niedrig
sind schon das casino immer gewinnt ist
eigentlich klar
man spielt trotzdem weil man natürlich
das system austricksen möchte und man
ist natürlich schlauer als das kann
du spielst immer weiter weil hier immer
denkt der nächste gewinn kommt die
videos bei youtube twitter zeigen wir
dass es möglich ist zu beginnen und du
willst diesen gewinn auch hamm china wie
knasti machen es vor
auf der plattform clipstream sie sich
selbst beim online glücksspiel mit
angeblich hohem einsatz und freuen sich
lautstark wenn sie gewinn auf youtube
und twitter erreichen diese videos
millionen klicks und tausende zuschauer
was aber haben die streamer davon die
tagein tagaus für andere ihr glücksspiel
stream was verdienen sie daran
wir wollen mit einem streamer sprechen
auftritts halten alle gerne ihr gesicht
in die kamera
aber zu einem interview ist kaum jemand
bereit schließlich finden wir jemanden
der mit uns spricht wenn auch anonym
wir nennen ihn kam sein kanal hatte
auftritts bis zu 70.000 follower und war
damit einer der größeren deutschen
zucker kanäle die illegalität hat ihn
nie abgeschreckt es gibt fast keine
urteile darüber dass mal ein casino
spieler oder ein casino verklagt worden
dass deutschland diese gesetzliche
grauzone ist mir bewusst ja wir arbeiten
auch bewusst sind damit dafür erstens
nichts verbotenes machen und zweitens
nichts erlaubt ist tatsächlich gab es in
der vergangenheit widersprüchliche
urteile in dieser grauzone machen
casinos ihre gewinne
karl verlor mal viel geld im online
casino er fragte sich wer alles an ihm
verdient habe und wechselte die seiten
wurde selbst thema ihres bevor ich diese
diese vergütungs art das an verlusten
der spieler wird der empfehler beteiligt
das heißt wenn das ein spieler kommt er
meldet sich über meinen empfehlungs
links spielt oder verliert 10 euro
dann bekomme ich im schnitt je nach stil
den ich gegangen bin
es ist ein 45 prozent oder 50 prozent
wenn jemand länger das beste spiel zum
einsatz und mehr geld verliert verdiene
ich natürlich mit
das ist ganz normales mädchen rechnung
offenbar geht es dem streamer gar nicht
um eigene gewinne seine verluste im
casino sind einkalkuliert das geld
verdient er nicht im casino sondern mit
seiner community die er zum spiel
verführt mit provision
den größten gewinn macht er mit leuten
wie sascha der spielsüchtig wurde und
tausende euro im online casino verspielt
hat bei mir drehte sich alles nur noch
um spielen das heißt den verlust den ich
erlebt hatte am vortag wieder
auszugleichen weil der gewinn ist er
nicht weit entfernt und du träumst halt
wirklich auch von den bildern die du
denn da siehst im moralische bedenken
nein habe ich nicht
jeder verdient irgendwo sein geld aber
das mit glücksspiel ist ob es jetzt mit
neuen normalen nine to five arbeiten
gegen ist es ist genauso ein profil hoch
ein beruf wie jeder andere auch die
neurologin dr monika vogelgesang
behandelt häufig online glücksspieler
auch sascha hat oft versucht mit dem
spielen aufzuhören doch durch online
casino videos und verlockung des streams
erlitt er immer wieder rückfälle die
spielsucht die sie nicht los ich habe
mir das angeguckt in zeiten wo ich dann
kein geld hatte zum spielen was mich
aber unglaublich getriggert zu spielen
denn dort wurde einem suggeriert dass
man mit geringem einsatz sehr viel geld
gewinnen kann
profiteure des spiels sind online
casinos sie setzen eine milliarde euro
jährlich allein in deutschland um ein
bericht der glücksspielaufsicht der
länder zeigte 2017
es gibt mehr als 730 casino angebote im
netz der top streamer cnosf verheimlicht
in welchem online casino er täglich
spielt alle casino narben sind in seinen
videos mit farbbalken versteckt nur in
einem video entdecken wir für einen
kleinen moment ein logo wunde rhinow
punkt com online casino deutschland
steht auf der website wunde rhinow
vermittelt den eindruck aus deutschland
zu kommen und hat auf der website ein
deutsches tüv-siegel die lizenz aus
schleswig holstein hat wundere ihn nicht
stattdessen finden wir auf der seite
eine andere lizenz die der malta gaming
authority auch als firmensitz wird eine
adresse in malta angegeben registriert
ist die firma hier genauso wie die
anderen glücksspiel anbieter tipico
mybet und heimkino auffallend viele
anbieter
warum gerade hier wir kontaktieren den
maltesischen journalisten immer neu
delhi an
er berichtet über organisierte
kriminalität korruption und auch über
das glücksspielgeschäft auf malta
von den directors depeschen hieß es
weiter dass online casinos ein paar
monate ist ein effektives vollcasinos
ist ein effekt der tiroler pedro mota
angetrieben license open country ich
mich nur noch bekannte
daher ist es für titel des companies and
do not resign monika walther lockt
unternehmer mit extrem niedrigen steuern
und wurde dadurch zu einem europäischen
eldorado für online casinos
das land profitiert von der
lizenzvergabe und den steuereinnahmen
denn alleine die glücksspielindustrie
trägt zu zwölf prozent der maltesischen
wirtschaftsleistung bei online casinos
kaufen in malta glücksspiellizenzen
damit bieten sie ihre dienste auch in
deutschland an
die wunde rhinow bekommen
dabei ist die rechtslage eindeutig das
urteil des europäischen gerichtshofs ist
ergangen in der sache liga portugiese
und das liegt ja schon mehrere jahre
zurück und seitdem ist aber wirklich
klar
die anbieter können sich nicht in
deutschland darauf berufen dass sie
beispielsweise eine genehmigung aus
malta oder gibraltar in der tasche haben
das reicht ihnen gerade nicht aus das
bedeutet vun der uno durfte seine
dienste in deutschland nicht anbieten
klassisch spiel auf wunden punkt com war
illegal
wir konfrontieren ihn mit den vorwürfen
keine antwort auch wunde rhinow
antwortet nicht auf unsere fragen
der markt ist milliardenschwer der
großteil des illegal erwirtschafteten
geldes fließt ins ausland youtuber und
streamer zeigen wie sie im internet um
geld spielen leidtragende sind tausende
spieler innen die die politik mit ihrer
legalisierung des online glücksspiels 20
21 im stich lasse kritisierte lona
füchtenschnieder leider haben die
anderen länder die eine mehrheit sind
sich nicht effektiv gewährt geben
schließlich holstein also da
das war ein einfallstor und man versucht
jetzt dieses modell der ganzen
bundesrepublik überzustülpen vom damit
viel lobby energie die länder
kapitulierten vor dem grenzenlosen
online glücksspiel
sie wollen lizenzen vergeben wie
schleswig holstein und hoffen so auf
mehr kontrolle
die suchtexperten hat zweifel besonders
skandalös ist aus unserer sicht dass die
bundesweite aufsichtsbehörde ja erst
viel später installiert ist die ganze
reihenfolge passt nicht auch sascha ist
gegen das neue gesetz
er ist den online casinos zum opfer
gefallen obwohl es sie gar nicht hätte
geben dürfen
für mich gehört online glücksspiel in
deutschland noch viel viel schärfer
eingeschränkt da müssen viel viel
schärfere instrumente hinter und vor
allen dingen auch dieser selbstschutz
für ein spieler der muss viel viel
größer werden
harmlose spiele oder gefährliche
zockerei denkt ihr online glücksspiel
sollte schärfer reguliert werden